hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast microbiome signatures in
gynecologic cancers it is presented by
marina Walther Antonio PhD an associate
consultant in the Department of Surgery
and department of obstetrics and
gynecology and an assistant professor in
the microbiome program at the Center for
individualized medicine at the Mayo
Clinic I am Judy O'Rourke of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab at the
top right corner of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits please join me in welcoming
dr. Walther Antonio I will now turn the
presentation over to her all right well
thank you very much for the invitation
to speak at this event and it's the
first is a virtual event so hopefully
this goes well
I'll be talking to you about the work
we've been doing on microbiome
signatures in gynecologic cancers but my
path is a little unusual and so I'd like
to take you along with me so that you
understand why I do what I do and the
way I do it
so my first slide is really on
disclosure of intellectual property we
do have some patents filed and some of
this work in that does limit my
to go into great detail on some of the
aspects and I apologize beforehand but
I'm happy to discuss some of those with
you if you're interested a later time
point so I'm European I was born in in
Portugal and work there and fortunately
is in Europe known in South America as I
often hear so that's the first
educational points of some people it is
a small country but it's a it's
beautiful as you can see there was
really a kind of the Venice of Portugal
where we have a nice Beach and I was
having a great life and then now I'm
here in in Rochester Minnesota Mayo
Clinic and that might seem kind of weird
why somebody would do such a change in
Napoli when what we've been doing here
justifies that drastic change in life
quality somehow in their environment so
I I was at the beach enlisted in my
University back home
and I have a dream to really work for
NASA and the astrobiology program which
is a program that looks into life in
other planets in Mars missions and those
sorts of things and I applied for an
internship there is an undergraduate and
I got in somehow
and went to the EPI Center Indiana Crist
and Tennessee astrobiology initiative
studying micro microbial life in Mars
like environments and what became clear
to me and others at the time during this
type of research is that what we
typically call extreme environments are
really extreme as humans not so extreme
to the microbes you know what we found
in those environments is that despite
their really very different conditions
than the ones we typically think is
habitable there's a huge diversity of
microbes and they're doing all very well
they were not struggling to live or
anything like that and so it kind of
changes your mind as to what his extreme
or not sometimes our body is more
extreme to these microbes than its
environment and then I went on to
continue in my graduate studies
continuing to study
topics in other environments such as
pitch lake and turn it out in tomorrow
which is a Titan analogue which is a
Saturn moon and then microbio lights in
the lake in Canada and these are analog
environments for Europa
when engineers use what became
particularly interesting in the
microlights
project in particular is that these
microchips you see here are microscopic
there's several meters high but they are
entirely built by microbes in the three
domains of life bacteria Eukarya and
then archaea and they are also intense
communication going on between them
which you know kind of brings to
awareness that the microbes aren't just
communicating or ingest Salons isolated
they communicate with each other and
they communicate with ourselves as well
you know and this has been an ongoing
feature of life whether we are aware of
it or not and that might become relevant
to our health as we think about these
things now just to put things in context
and I like to show this slide just
because everybody and I love it I think
most people have seen this slide where
it shows kind of the life of history of
life on Earth and how humans appear
seconds to midnight and the walk was a
24-hour clock and it's humbling in many
ways but really when we look at this
this is really our story this is not the
story really a life on Earth this is how
we aim to me so it leads to kind of a
paradigm shift because when you look at
the universal train wife and looking in
terms of genetic diversity this is a lot
more what watching Lucy and and you can
see where you are there and Homo sapiens
right next to corn and mushrooms barely
distinguishable from each other if you
compare say I will media for him across
tritium and the bacteria to me are much
further different genetically than we
are from further mushrooms which is a
sum of a shift change so this is
to keep for us to become aware of really
you know our metabolic capacity and how
different we really are compared to
these microorganisms are extremely
diverse and if you have in your body the
medium versus our quest rhenium that's
very very different type of organism
then you know to complicate things
further now with what we currently know
as well you know or is it there's there
some horizontal you know gene transfer
occurring between microorganisms that
really need to be aware and you know
what you see here in this scheme is all
that history the bottom of that diagram
shows you all the events that are taking
place in terms of horizontal gene
transfer and how they reflect into
modern days which is red so it's not
like these bacteria are older than
that's all the bacteria that are
currently living with us are as modern
as we are they are here at the same time
as we are and they have complex
evolutionary history and what they have
been doing throughout that history
matters to me they are to me insanely it
does for us so those are things to take
into account when we're thinking about
you know what this organisms actually
are doing and communicating with us and
so there's this new notion now of the
whole of biomes that I don't really like
that really brings that for that idea
that we are not we are not just the
water genes we are a complex combination
of our genes and the genes of the
microbes that live with us an important
part to think about this is that it's
not just that we all are together in
manifesting in our phenotype is more
than because of this evolutionary
history that we've had with our partners
microbes and our body expects those
microbes to be there to fulfill some of
the functions and if they are not that's
when disease can can happen and so it's
kind of thinking that it's not just a
fun fact that for my traumas there is
that sometimes or you get involved to
really rely on on those functions and if
they are missing we really have a
problem so and further to think about
what is it that we know and what we
don't know when you think about the
bacterial species that have been
described to date there's about 7,000
bacterial species in the area
to grow and and identify in comparison
there's about 1.2 million insects and
remind you that they're insects have
their own microbiome that we also are
studying so there's a really a huge
amount of information we just see um and
this is due to unknown requirements and
interdependency and slow growth that we
just are beginning to understand about
the bacteria and therefore we have to
rely on some techniques that did not
rely on fact that we could culture them
or knots and those are culture three
technologies think genomics
transcriptomics whatever we'll mix all
those things you might have heard of and
so the next generation sequencing table
technologist um in microbiome because
we'll see if it slides about that we
also rely a lot in talking about alpha
diversity and beta diversity and what
does that mean so there's this diagram
that you can see there with the fishes
for example and you can see you know you
can simplify these types of concepts by
thinking about the diversity as a
diversity within a site so say site
eight has three different colors of fish
and then they can be present at
different rates and other sites or they
can be colors can change and that would
be kind of a beta diversity is when you
compare site a and B is so many fish are
different and the more fish that are
different the more the bigger the
distance between the points in a graph
for example and I'll get back to that
notion but just it's kind of a good way
to think about to just retain that in
your in your mind so what's the
microbiome role in cancer what's out
there that has been quite a few out
there lately
um microbiome can be involved in the
causation of cancer potentially
certainly infection trauma dietary
factors and all other things I can cause
very or breach that that can lead to
microbes being where they shouldn't
lobby and that can then leads to
persistent barrier breach where it can
cause some dysfunctions at the level of
the immune system in microbial obvious
stasis and there you see is
effect there's also some thought that
can be involved in progression and
progression either with direct DNA
damage by toxins being produced or
indirectly through the production of
oxygen reactive species it can also
interfere with signaling and another
course inflammatory programs in
treatment there's also been quite a few
of published papers now on the good
effect of my career and the bad which
can change between different cancers
between different drug types and here
you see some examples of some beneficial
and beneficial effects of microbes but
either way you probably have to take
into account whether they're present or
not and whether antibodies are a good
thing you're not for a particularly case
the active studies we're doing are on
primarily on endometrial cancer
prevention and detection and ovarian
cancer detection the treatment and that
has to do with the needs of the material
cancer is although a lot of people
aren't not necessarily aware is is the
most common gynecologic cancer is in
fact the fourth most common cancer in
women and it is as common as leukemia as
you see there and it's actually more
lethal than melanoma
NIH has also predicted that by 2030 will
surpass the incidence rates of colon
cancer so something to wrestle with
nothing changes you know and then we set
up a study with dr. Andrea Mariani a
gynecologic oncology surgery here at
Mayo and we did was to look at the
microbiome of patients as they were and
they're going in hysterectomy so the
removal of the uterus by either for a
benign disease and they see some
examples there fibroids or products or
other things and refer and then we kill
cancer diagnosis and we set up a
starting field in pathology where we can
I collect sterile samples and we conduct
these types of studies so we published
our work a while back showing
kind of move her signal for endometrial
cancer that was interesting and now we
have a new cohort that is under review
of 151 patients you continue to see see
a beta diversity plot remember about the
pushing the colors so you see cancer
kind of in blue and then you see with
benign in green few hyperplasia cases
which are pre cancer states you can
appreciate how they are in different
spaces and so the cancer patients really
clustered differently than the benign
and this is based only on the microbiome
together
I'm if you were to do a UC curve of that
you'd get a point maybe 687 which is
pretty decent and there was a particular
microbe that really light up and then
the data which was just for - species
that seems to be the prevalent in cancer
patients not so much the nine patients
then you see a very significant p-value
we also see Kimberly for a false
discovery correction that it's still
very low
if you compare these numbers to say HPV
numbers or h pylori numbers with
cervical cancer and gastric cancer and
respectively you see that our
specificity is actually a little better
although assists omitting that so much
and that has to do just with I was
identifying what type of patient
population we want to target and as we
know HPV is finally prevalent in women
the younger women only becomes a problem
later in life so these are things that
we need to understand about the disease
as well and understand what the
population and can better at a benefit
turn this down
um so we developed also something in the
review right now the blind qpcr test for
for detection in the vaginal environment
so this is something that women could do
vaginal swab and know whether they have
the microorganism or not what we found
is that this is the micro correlates
very well with BMI and obesity so if you
have which is a risk factor for
endometrial cancer so and you have
obesity or high BMI erat risk increase
your risk for individual cancer and
having a bacteria we also found that
this marker has point 86 positive
predictive value in high-risk population
meaning if you are opposed to going to
cause a woman who is obese and has this
microbe you are according to our data
you have 86 percent chance of having
individual cancer and should probably be
tested so these are things that we kind
of discovering in there we also kind of
interrogating whether this can be more
than an association and we we have kind
of hypothesis driven projects to find
out here I'm just showing you in kind of
evasion assays we did with one a summary
which isn't species and Kenny Elise it
aligns which isn't in the Metreon
selling we see the first lot there is a
fish fluorescence in situ hybridization
type of assay where we see some signs of
invasion but what we didn't anticipate
was that we would see cytoplasmic
swelling in which indicates some
necrotic impact we didn't really
anticipate but intense light makes sense
since that it would mean that the host
is not really in control about what is
happening and this is what has been now
associated with each gloria's one so
interesting there and then the other s
is just a cell trace showing that the
bacteria are much happier in green it
shows the live cells and in right are
the dead cells and you can see that the
green cells really but the life cells
like in green really like to be a ghost
ourselves so how do we go about studying
these things though it is a complex
environment with all the complexities
that were just discussed so everybody is
study this and the way I approach it is
kind of thinking in terms of micro
ecology how would you do this so if you
were to study in this you know community
studies in Savannah there's gonna be a
lot of species there you know if you're
thinking about what's bad let's say that
hosts thinking about it as near the
grass and you you have all benefits from
having this herbivores kind of grazing
your grass and fertilizing more soil but
some of them may be the boars they
attract predators they really would like
to keep away so that doesn't disturb the
delivery so
about kind of introducing change or
determining what what's beneficial or
not and if you are thinking in terms of
an analogy what we do in terms of
microbiology where we are able to do
right now this is all any approach would
be to find ahead of the war that kind of
looks like that and it's easy to work
with and put them in a very confined
space and kind of grow this is a colony
type approach right so you grow these
microorganisms and plates and care
cultures and you try to understand
disease like that um it is what it is
and it's not a criticism necessarily but
it's bringing awareness so that's
probably not the best paradigm not to
have and that's limited just by what we
can't take much believed in right now
but given my background with NASA and
all that you know really if things
aren't working out in terms technology
and that it's not sufficient to
answering problems then maybe you want
to change that and so let's so this is
kind of how I see it how we in our
studying microbiology right now is
though I mean we have a plain vision
that looks like this so pixelated hard
to make sense of it maybe we are Goering
to a state aware is like this about what
I would really like to get is to the
state that micron colleges can do which
is observe their study you know subjects
and I like this picture for many reasons
one of them is if we were to please
something like this without knowing
anything else you probably think that
this is the predator and that's the prey
you know well we know that that's not
the case because we've seen this long
enough to know that's the other way
around but the other thing that is
interesting about this this image is
that you see that the Buffalo is turning
on the lion there but it's only doing
that because it's not outnumbered right
otherwise it wouldn't be doing that and
we have to think about bacteria in that
way as well because there's a lot of
bacterial communication and was called
form sensing and form quenching where
then he can change behavior depending on
the context what they perceived to be
threats threatening environment or not
so we really need to think about those
things and this is just another strength
that we only need to look hard enough to
really find the real relation
and we have you know it's kind of what I
really would like to to see it's kind of
this ant Juarez area like the idea that
you could see through kind of a system
and and really understand what's
happening in the inside and this would
be a great system so what looks like
that and this is what I call kind of a
microbiome dollhouse and which is
microwaves technology this this
particular platform which is one of the
ones we're using it's called an optical
it explan horn and the concept was
developed by Fellini at Stanford who is
now at Protista TV and this involves
basically animist microscope with laser
tweezers that can facilitate the
movement of bacteria you can use a
MATLAB explains your face we can move
the cells with a mouse like and then it
has a micro filari system and that's to
really work in small dimensions which
other countries for the microbes we also
work in collaboration for scale from the
University of Utah which can
mass-produce
if we do a design and a prototype
testing and then we want to produce a
hundred of these things um you know that
he can he can make it make it happen and
that's been incredibly useful also Kevin
Bennett here at the in the Birdman of
engineering at Mei okay Nana has a group
of sixteen to seventeen years that
really helped us I kind of put the parts
together and and just interfaces as we
need them this case you see here is an
interface to create to my career hillock
environment I'm very adamant about
studying our own cells and their true
environment and that's not not be
atmospheric levels of oxygen like like
most people do which is a 21 percent
level of oxygen that's not reflective of
what the cells experience in our body at
five percent oxygen so much more
realistic he'd been below timrie
environments go down to two or one
percent at times and we should be
studying at them like that because
oxygen has a huge impact on how they
respond to their environment
interactions um and so we are take
question with it um you wanna leave is a
very
talented engineer in my team and I think
he won't be able to see these videos but
it was just basically showing food
colouring through channels and how we
can kind of control those flows and this
also has a few a few videos I'm happy to
share all these videos of it you learn
if you wish but they just show how you
can move the cells with a simple click
of a mouse and kind of see how they
react to that movements they're kind of
neat videos in that again happy to share
I'll just jump me anymore though
I'll be happy to send them to you so we
we have published recently on the
development of effective bacterial cell
lysis um for whole genome single cell
whole genome amplification in platforms
we chose these three microorganisms
because they're notoriously difficult to
work with and we wanted to show that our
protocols could work with positives gram
negative periodic microorganisms as well
and you can see how we managed to do
that and we can sequence that data
without much problem so we can do all
these studies at a very fine detailed
level so in summary for the endometrial
cancer part i'd like you to retain that
the microbiome biomarker could be at a
clinical value with the 0.86 positive
predictive value you know bees and
postmenopausal women this could have
some clinical application also that the
organism we found associated with the
disease might have some in it there's we
have evidence of innovation and a
necrotic impact and others as we study
the different hypotheses and we are we
are studying a pose I can't go into the
details of them right now but you know
happy to discuss that a later time
points on the ovarian cancer project a
much different type of disease doesn't
need a whole lot of introduction people
seem to be more aware of it because it
is so deadly busy seether them sixty
percent of the cases are found when they
are metastatic and that leads to less
than 30 percent survival rate survival
and that's really
money so we did kind of a study to try
to see if we could find anything similar
to what we found in the material cancer
and unfortunately you know we weren't
able to find that light at the end of
the tunnel for ovarian cancer you see
here the plots you see the first one is
off the diversity so thinking how many
different colored fish there are within
the benign ovarian cancer and what you
see is that there's no significant value
so this is not gonna be a story of you
can do a vaginal swab and know if you
have a microorganism that puts you at
risk for ovarian cancer we really don't
see that in ovarian unfortunately and
you see that in beta as well we can't
distinguish the populations where the
Amerian with it with a vaginal or
cervical swab but indeed the metrium and
changes a lot of the story changes a
little bit so we can see and appreciate
that the ovarian cancer here on your
left on the alpha diversity does have
less of my less less microbes then our
less diversity of microbes ten to the
nine group even though we can't quite
distinguish them and in the beta
diversity plots but they do seem to have
a loss of diversity and we don't know
why that would be the case other than
think that there could be some immune
involvement into you know intolerance
for some microbes that might be
beneficial we do see the same trend in
the ovarian tissue when you look at the
ovaries of cancer patients versus
ovaries of patients that did not have a
variant cancer we see that also that
trend loss and we can actually
distinguish two groups in the beta
diversity so we can distinguish the
microbiome of an ovarian cancer from an
ovary of somebody look up an eye disease
this is not really you know terribly
this really there was a biomarker kids
didn't want to be accessing the ovarian
tissue necessarily but it can leads to
some great findings for mechanistic
purposes and trying to understand what's
happening in the disease kind of an
incidental finding was that the
microbiome might be
predictive of treatment outcomes so as
part of our collection in your we
collected vaginal swabs and cervical
swabs and screams and you run through
the catheter and we also did a pelvic
wash or collected ascites like the
patient side it and what you see there
is that you know we as part of kind of
reviewing all the patients are doing
later on and kids pulling them up and
these are patients who followed for the
next two years after collection and see
whether they are responding to treatment
or not and what you see there and again
this is based solely on the microbiome
data you can see that patients are on
remission look different than the ones
that are in progression two years later
but it's just on the ascites microbiome
at the time of surgery before they have
any treatment and so there could be you
know in the similar story to what we are
now seeing with the pancreatic cancer
that there are some microbes that can
impact the resistance to drugs we could
be thinking we could be seeing something
similar in ovarian cancers we do not see
this in other sample types we didn't
look for this in them you know vaginal
samples or the uterine samples or even
ovarian the ascites was the one that
correlated with response and there could
be some meaning to that we are
investigating that we also have the
ovarian cancer treatment project where
what we are doing here is looking into
the role of metformin in the cancer
recurrence what you see there in the
plots in the middle is that if you look
closely you'll see that there's the red
line our diabetic patients taking
metformin and then you see the blue and
the non diabetic patients and the yellow
diabetic patients not taking metformin
and what's striking about this both on
the top plot which is a probability of
recurrence and the bottom plot the
probability of survival is that you see
the diabetic patients taking metformin
do better than even non diabetic
patients this is very surprising as you
would expect that a comorbidity of this
type would become you know
leads to poor outcomes and leads do you
think that there is some some kind of
world that metformin might have cancer
returns and this has been verified in
Mouse animal models as well so what we
are now doing is that we have a clinical
trial with the University of Chicago
where click on face to a medical trial
where we are enrolling patients and at
the time of surgery we either put them
on a placebo or a metformin and then we
collect samples and throughout their
their treatments so at the enrollment
and their Lots chemotherapy treatment
and then following as to you follow-up
doctor therapy to see how they're doing
and we don't have results yet and we're
about half a year from finishing this
timeframe um but we are looking and what
we are trying to see is whether there is
a microbiome correlation with the
response that the patients have
benefiting I can as to whether patient
responds really we don't have another
arm to this study which is a
patient-derived xenograft model and here
we kind of mimicking what we're doing
with the patients so we have mice that
just aren't control they're just they
have the cancer and they're not treated
for it and then others are just given
metformin others that are given a
chemotherapy treatment carboplatin plus
Beckley taxol chemotherapy and then the
fourth group that is given both the
chemotherapy treatment and the metformin
and see what happens to them and the
results we have indicate preliminary
results you don't have the results for
all the models we will be I think those
soon but to preliminary ones we have as
you see there on the left is that this
is a chemo sensitive model so the model
that responds to treatment and we don't
really see a difference between the
combo which is
metformin and the chemotherapy and the
chemotherapy alone they both respond to
treatment looking value the significance
is between the metformin control versus
there but when we look into microbiome
what we do see is that there is some
effect of the metformin here so you see
on the first first plot there for spar
is in control and that's the number of
species observed and then you see
chemotherapy really drags that down and
kinda impacts that microbial microbial
diversity and this is in the gut so we
know that a loss of diversity tends to
equal kind of health problems um but
when you add my department to document
therapy treatment you kind of rescue
that phenotype you don't see that even
though the mouse does as well in terms
of I'm you know response to treatment
they look much healthier and actually we
have you know they're indicating that
they are you know their fur looks better
they just look in better health overall
and I can correlate to the microbiome
and so we're thinking that nickimja
sensitive models maybe there isn't much
of a you know difference in terms of the
impact on the cancer itself but on the
overall health which could be very
significant and patients still and make
a difference in their life where the
chemo resistant models there does seem
to be an impact as you see here the the
combo is the blue line at the bottom and
even though it doesn't completely make
the changes that the phenotype of the
mice to be become sensitive to the
therapy it does lead to a drastic
reduction of the growth of the tumor so
it kind of seems to sensitize
potentially the tumor to respond to
treatment microbiome we we don't have a
whole lot of data points as you see here
and we're adding some more mice to this
hard to tell here if there's gonna be an
effect or not the chemo resistant models
just do very poorly throughout this time
this treatment what we didn't see it but
in the beta diversity even though you
know to go back one even though the
didn't say the number of microbes
weren't different in the key more
resistant the type of microbes that are
present are different and I'm nect
misison not really but on the
or resistant they are so it seems like
the treatments can leads to a change of
actual community and what's present and
there can make a difference in their
welcome so we are investigating that so
very cancer summary where I'd like you
to retain the microbiome use may be
possible in the uterus it's probably not
in the vaginal tract unfortunately but
theaters would still be very helpful for
the patients there really there is no
screening for ovarian cancer as we all
know and this would still be something
very viable to assess the uterine
environment as a proxy um also ascites
microbiome composition may be predictive
of treatment outcome we'll have to
continue to look into this but it would
be an interesting finding and then could
be also have some impact on patient
treatment let's form in microbiome
action seems differential between chemo
resistance and chemo sensitive our
models again we are adding data to this
to this work but there might be
something that is a fundamentally
different in that includes microbiome as
well and we are studying and have some
grant funding for some of that
hypothesis driven mechanisms of
metformin a microphone impact on host
and that involves some drug testing and
just to finalize and I think everyone
involved you saw the faces of a lot of
those and wealth along the way it is a
team effort
as usual and you know the needs of the
patient come first I really like this
cartoon they see there on the left that
says medicine meets research and
research needs people like you to make
sure they've got it right I really have
to thank the patients first and foremost
for allowing us to do this even though
they know that their health is not
really going to benefit from that most
likely and they still do it because they
want to help others and that's very
inspiring given the difficult situation
they're in and their diagnosis I'm also
thinking of course the funding and then
it is can be possible without money
obviously and there's different funding
to make sure you know
see they're hidin Elson I really would
like to thank her in particular she is
the microbiome director also the chair
of surgery and she has really had the
vision to put together a very
interdisciplinary team that it's not you
know the most common one especially in
May of a sort of specialized times and
so it's really refreshing to have her as
a leader in that program and also Scott
Kaufmann book why we have been mentors
for both MAGIX and thank you for
listening and I hope you learned
something interesting
spike your interest in there thank you
dr. Walter we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers
yes if you have any questions like these
just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
question into the box it appears on your
screen and click the send button our
speaker will follow up with your
questions let's get started first
question is what is the applicability of
microfluidic technologies to cancer
research so I think microfluidics
technologies are really changing the way
we do things you know I kind of cover
that through the presentation in terms
of paradigm shifts as thinking about my
Kurt's function at their own scale at
the runtime rather than what's
convenient or as impossible for us to do
while we are exploring the different
micro fluidics platforms the one that I
covered today was an optics which is a
very specialized tool that means
Alaric's parties to be run but once kind
of the complexity of the problem is
found then and we are already doing that
then we can move into other platforms
such as droplet pellet forms and that
digital micro fluidics we chart a lot
more I could automate it and it can be
portable even implantable in some cases
and then really a definitely you have
that is potentially in a usable by this
point of care even and some of them
including paper micro fluidics resentful
even by the patient's themselves so I
think there's there's extreme value to
these technologies to not only help us
understand the disease but also change
potentially change the way we test for
disease and how we use it as clinical
markers thank you for that next one is
how could these tests be implemented as
diagnostic or treatment platforms for
cancer patients right so building on the
question before so I think that micro
Phenix technologies they are they are
expensive to start there are you know it
takes a little bit to to get the
expertise to get the resources get the
space to really invest in this but then
the running cost of this technologies is
actually quite cheap because we're
talking of working with many leaders
right but rather than microliters you
really bring the cost down and sometimes
two or three orders of magnitude which
really allows you to to run these and
comparable or cheaper costs and their
current tests and they're much faster so
you know while you have to wait four
days for a quality to grow with micro
fluidics technologies you can detect a
replication of cells and minutes and
we're talking at really a real-time type
of testing and being feasible and going
from sample collection to sequencing
results can feasibly to be done in hours
and in the end of my committee's
platform which you know you really do a
very precise treatment personalized
treatment of patients based on these
technologies I think it's it transform
medicine and I'm looking forward to it
to see we can help patients with ease
thank you for that I would like to once
again thank dr. Walter Antonio for her
presentation but also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go on 11 let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January 11th 2019
you'll receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that
is all for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon bye